pour aux navires us c'est le mot ultime
qui depuis plusieurs jours affole la
planète entière coronavirus venus de
chine traversent chaque jour un peu plus
les frontières du monde entier causant
l'inquiétude quant à son important de
propagation qui ne semble connaître
aucune limite
malgré les précautions prises par les
autorités françaises le virus a été
signalée dans l'hexagone à l'heure où
nous parlons 4k de coronavirus 2019 nc
au v ont été avérés en france selon les
autorités ces sujets revenaient tous
directement de chine où il avait
séjourné durant les premières semaines
de l'épidémie
ces personnes ont été placées en
isolement et serait aujourd'hui hors de
danger ces derniers jours en france les
chaînes infos font monter la pression
autour de ce mystérieux virus dont on
ignore encore l'origine exacte pour
l'heure le coronavirus a fait 80
victimes dans le monde entier
selon les derniers chiffres publiés par
des chercheurs hong kong et le virus
aurait déjà contaminé plus de quarante
quatre mille individus majoritairement
en chine dont la ville de maurane est
l'épicentre de cette catastrophe
sanitaire en ce moment ce sont plus de
56 millions de chinois qui ont été
placés en quarantaine avec interdiction
formelle de quitter une zone délimitée
par les autorités c'est une véritable
course contre la montre qui s'est
engagée pour lutter contre la
propagation de ce virus
alors faut-il avoir peur du coronavirus
faut-il avoir peur du coronavirus on
aura aujourd'hui on se rend skype dans
un instant avec une personne qui se
trouve donc à lui à lui annonce chine il
est 4 heures du matin là bas elle va
nous dire nous donner encore quelques
d'informations merci de me mohamed
d'être c'est mon jimmy est ce que est ce
que vous en avez peur vous faut-il avoir
peur du commandant virus est ce que vous
êtes angoissé but guillaume de tonquédec
est ce que vous y pensez ou pas du tout
quatre cas on est cinq millions de
licences et oui non ça va pas l'être non
plus le délire
pour le moment six minutes ce sera
inquiétant mais pour l'instant vous
n'êtes pas super inquiet jérémy non plus
un mot change c'était sur les menaces là
comme tu les laisses adria clatot cité
comme moi moi j'ai une angine suis-je
pas bien mais moi dès que j'ai quelque
chose je crois que j'ai ça moi aussi et
que j'ai trouvé un truc l'avenir je
n'étais pas bien je pareil ah ouais
l'appareil malin tu as lessard et ben je
sais c'est pas bien ça passe me voir au
cabinet je prends deux ans entre deux je
vois ce que je peux faire
alors oui j'ai envie chez le maire moi
je suis très inquiet parce que la
maladie par de chine et on ne peut pas
dire que la chine c'est la plus grande
démocratie dans le monde et que pour
qu'il soit se sentent obligées de
communiquer sur le virus et commence à
donner des chiffres
c'est vraiment la maladie je pense est
beaucoup plus imprégné iran chine
qu'elle n'est qu'il n'ose le dire et je
pense le corner vrai chivan sortir c'est
comme le nuage de tchernobyl qui avait
évité strasbourg mais repoussé par le
virus là je pense qu'il est beaucoup
plus important on croit et quand ça va
péter ça va être très très gratifiant
janssen qu'il n'y a pas quelqu'un vient
pas chine et qu'il a reçues et jean
michel a raison parce qu'en fait les
chercheurs anniversaire de hong kong ont
dit que les nombres de castres était à
multiplier par 15 et qu'en fait il ya
peut-être une rétention d'informations
de la part des chinois puisqu'ils ont eu
peur de diffuser l'information et donc
irait peut-être beaucoup plus de cas que
ce qu'on dit actuel alors déjà qu'est ce
que c'est pour les téléspectateurs
allemands nous le corps d'un virus qui
font la vanne en ce moment l'om bien les
lourdeurs oued en moi je suis là c'est
64 comment je peux pas l'avoir voilà
alors déjà on avait recours aux navires
us puisque il a une forme de couronne
lorsqu'on aura d'un microscope d'où ce
nom la salle virus qu'on connaît déjà
en france on en a quatre types il ya un
cinquième qui le sera ce qu'on connaît
il ya eu l'épidémie au moyen-orient qui
a touché beaucoup de monde et puis à ce
7e qu'on appelle le 2019 enkov donc
c'est un virus qu'on connaît déjà et qui
tue déjà en france un professeur
d'infectiologie à marseille nous
explique que chaque année on estime à
500 ou 600 les personnes qui meurent de
façon normale du corona virus donc on
est peut-être en train de faire une
psychose sur un virus chinois car comme
il vient de chine il serait loin il
serait peut-être dangereux parce qu'en
plus peut-être que le chinois nous
mentent donc il ya un peu de fantasmes
peut-être de la part des gens alors on
va voir les c'était la première question
il n'aura cinq à dix mille et nous
répondre mais j'aurai complété mais il
ya du flou autour de cette maladie est
ce que c'est déjà une maladie qu'on
connaît mais apparemment on a du mal à
l'analyse et à la d
finir c'est ça qui crée quoi les
symptômes alors alors les symptômes le
problème c'est que ça va de la simple du
simple petit rhume vous avez le nez qui
coule des courbatures un peu de fièvre à
la bronchite voir la pneumonie la
pneumopathie chez certaines personnes
pour l'instant les plus fragiles des
personnes âgées des gens qui ont des
problèmes respiratoires
ça peut aller jusqu'au décès mais ce
n'est pas dit que a même dit russe
donnera les mêmes symptômes chez tout le
monde
avant alors vous allez réveiller vous en
avez peur non mais après tu me poserai
des cinq questions là je veux savoir
notre ami gilles verdez moi je suis pas
dit qu et jimmy il est convaincant mais
j'ai l'impression que les autorités nous
montrent au début on met des affiches
dans les aéroports alors tous les autres
mesures la température des gens après on
nous dit on laisse nos ressortissants
web maintenant dit qu'on va les sortir
en urgence en avion on a toujours un
temps de retard
j'ai l'impression que tous pouvoirs
publics ne maîtrise rien moi je vous le
dis je suis au bord d'aller m'acheter
des masques alors alors alors est-ce que
les matches ça sert à quelque chose
strictement rien à ce stade
d'ailleurs les gens souvent confondent
les deux choses il achète le masque
chirurgical
le petit masque qui ne sert strictement
à rien sur lui un masque de de sarko
sarko d'autres anniversaires aujourd'hui
rôle embrasser le masque chirurgical
classique c'est celui qui permet
d'éviter de contaminer les autres
vous l avez la grippe vous ne voulez pas
que votre enfant tombe malade vous
mettez un masque si vous voulez vraiment
être protégés des autres c'est le masque
canard ce qui est plus difficile à
porter mais sait on appelle m à gilberto
et malheureusement ce masque est
efficace que quatre heures
il est inutile de se ruer dans les
pharmacies qui sont en rupture de stock
et certains vendeurs sur internet ou
ailleurs ont fait flamber les prix
karine psychose et le gouvernement a
annoncé que s'il y avait besoin des
masques il ya plusieurs millions des
dizaines de millions de masques en stock
et qu'on pourra les distribuer à la
population
donc pas besoin d'aller en formation en
acheter mais alors comment il se
transmet le virus alors le problème
c'est que sa part d'un virus qui
ressemble à un virus control chez la
chauve souris n'ont apparemment rien en
cause c'est parti comme ça en chine est
en fait cette chauve-souris aurait
contaminé un animal qui aurait été mangé
ou qui aurait contaminé un vendeur
chinois sur le marché de one qui ensuite
a muté et s'est transmis aux autres
personnes à ce stade le virus a peu
évolué sous sa part ça partirait bien
choisi
c'est ce que je vis de la sérieuse on a
le nom de touriste et bah oui on a les
coordonnées de cette chauve souris pour
l'instant les domaines l'instant le
virus ce qu'on souhaite ce virus il se
transmet la même façon que vous
transmettez la grippe par le contact les
gouttelettes salivaires dans éternuer
vous positionner mais alors là vous
comme un bref plus bacille de la
tuberculose
il est devenu par les crachats part ça
c'est votre assistante
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
assistante dentaire côté là là là mais
n'ajuste poser une question à jimmy
parce que j'ai vu sur twitter aussi des
gens qui s'inquiétaient et qui inondent
notamment sos médecins et autres alors
j'ai mangé oui j'ai chialé disent
déjeuner chez un restaurant chinois où
j'ai pris un traiteur chinois jeu risqué
notamment ont pas mangé une chaussure
n'est fait des tweets son coeur et ses
terres en disant arrêtez de nous appelle
là même un mec sur twitter qui dit j'ai
regardé le film batman est ce que je
risque non mais c'est vrai que les samu
sont débordés ils ont une suractivité
notamment des gens qui posent des
questions surréaliste j'ai mangé chinois
asiatique est ce que je risque quelque
chose non la même façon qu'on se
demandait ce que si je commande sur
aliexpress wish i mais est ce que j'ai
un risque de contamination
non la réponse est non le virus ne
survit pas sur une surface inerte au
bout de quelques heures à 500 milliards
d'eur 2 ème à la maladie mais en ce cas
là bas ni un bonheur de pâtes aussi la
part de jimmy quand même de minimiser le
risque et la peur que l'on pourrait
avoir parce que j'imagine il se passe
vraiment quelque chose tu seras bien
malin avoir dit que canon fallait pas
suivre la même stratégie mais lors des
goûters palais
on va vous donner un chiffre
la grippe tue chaque année entre 10 et
15 une personne mais pour autant on a un
vaccin est vite mortalité mais les gens
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
et là on a couronné de l'ours tout d'un
coup qui affole les passions je peux
comprendre si on compare le taux de
mortalité
le strass son taux de mortalité de
l'épidémie qu'on avait eu du coup ça
notre combat là virus en 2003 que sera
lavé où il s'appelle le strass le
syndrôme de détresse sociale est
innocent des gens on est aux alentours
de 3 à 4%
il a great actuellement et belle tuant
peu à peu près 0 5 % des gens mais ça
fait ça fait plus peur à l'ordre m on
peut mais la grippe moi j'ai toujours
vécu avec depuis je suis tout petit j'en
maintenant on parle de la grippe en
assumant personnes âgées faut être
vaccinés quentin à la gorge suivent à la
pharmacie tu prends une pastille là on
voit des gens tomber 80 morts ils
tombent comme des mouches et on a si je
te dis peut-être une bêtise en utilisant
ils ont mis au confinement
on va essayer la millions et 60 millions
c'est presque la france mais s'il n'y
avait rien ne bloque pas tu m'as bien
sûr sans cacher alors je vous dire vous
avez parlé il ya des scientifiques qui
tentent toujours de trouver l'origine de
bruit et comme vous avez dit on pense
que ça venait des poissons et il semble
au début mais il semblerait que ça
viendrait des chauves-souris donc quand
vous avez et une vidéo qui fait le tour
des réseaux c'est la soupe de chauves
souris
si vous êtes en train de manger je le
dis moi j'ai un
[Rires]
on a débordé
[Musique]
alors oui ça si ça c'est assez d'ego
alors il ya beaucoup de gens qui posent
et qu'il ya un monsieur qui dit voilà
j'ai commandé un paquet va la regarder
est ce que cette maladie peut se
retrouver dans des colis reversé en
chine si une personne et un chinois
éternue sur un paquet dessine à la
france et d'après ce que j'ai commandé
un truc j'ai commandé des chroniqueurs
oui la réponse est non on rigole mais
les caisses les gens sont vraiment ces
questions et la réponse est évidemment
non en moins de quelques heures
le virus ne survit pas car il a besoin
d'un hôte et la besoin d'un homme ils se
transmettent et survivre sur une surface
inerte au bout de quelques heures
il n'existe il va nous sommes en sommes
donc il va d'homme à homme et donc sur
un colis au bout de quelques heures il
meurt et donc vous n'êtes plus malades
dont vous pouvez commander si vous le
souhaitez d'accord et on peut parler
comme ça qu'une personne elle nous
postillonne de sumo vous respirez et là
vous tombez malade de mains de la même
façon qu'on attrape la grippe non
hinault pharyngite une bronchite une
bronchiolite
ça reste un virus respiratoires enfin
pas mourir il vous remarquez vous plaît
souvent je me pose la question comment
vous ne tombez pas malade je peux
apporter de l'armée vous voyez beaucoup
de monde et bien sachez que vous serrez
la main augmente le risque de
transmettre une maladie
mieux vaut faire la bise parce que la
main je fais quelque chose qui est plus
allez vous vous embrasser les gens
voient les gens qui me parlent
william andré louis nous devons faire la
bise jeu calloc'h même équité faire
quelque chose mieux vaut même éviter de
faire la mission peut alors juste un
petit chèque en période d'épidémie et ça
c'est mieux que je fais voilà en ce
moment éviter la bise ou s'il va même la
bisbal a fait un petit chèque rapide
mais on vous dit bonjour de l'autre ça
va on s'est vus les jours je vous
connais ces mecs au bureau servir
arrivent le matin ils valent absolument
te dire bonjour ont subi hier voilà on
continue les gens meilleurs qui a peur
alors vous n'avez pas peur pas soit
parce que vous êtes déjà des musées des
salles de ce côté est ce que vous pouvez
vous vous êtes déjà passé dans le dollar
une entier pour gondry yak donc déjà
j'ai pas une nature à avoir peur comme
ça c'est pour animaux n'a pas raisonné
elle est normal c'est la peur panique
que je déteste parce que de morale ne
sert à rien elle n'empêche pas les trucs
d'arrivée et ensuite ça entraîne des
comportements totalement à sociaux comme
elle est dévalisé des pharmacies et des
stocks à plat et tout et puis en plus on
a peur du corona virus mais ce que vous
savez qu'en ce moment les banquises
fondent et met à jour des animaux qui
sont pour tous porteurs du virus dans
son ego science mais avoir par un apport
d'absolument sûr mais ça fait flipper je
suis désolé
alors je vous dis il ya un vent de
panique regardez les chinois sont au
taquet en quelques jours ils ont lancé
la construction d'un hôpital
je vous dis c'est complètement ouf
regardez les images c'est incroyable
l'image est sûre réaliste des dizaines
et des dizaines de tractopelle qui
construisent salat un nouvel hôpital
pour lutter contre un virus étrange qui
sévit dans la ville de roanne une
frénésie qui contraste avec les rues
désertes
la ville a été placée en quarantaine
[Musique]
c'est incroyable vous lis ce qui se
passe là bas et on a deux personnes en
direct de vue and an chinois hans kaï et
ouais les mecs quoi nicolas les voilà le
jeune voilà qui sont directs il est 4
heures du matin là bas il ya jonathan 22
ans informaticien
c'est sur lui avec la casquette et il ya
rémy 33 ans consultant bonjour bonjour
jean netter et rémy désolé de vous
déranger en pleine nuit un bonjour voila
si on peut voir du som s'il vous plaît
parce que je savais que c'était une
mauvaise idée mais entre l'envié d'être
là alors comment est la situation chez
vous est ce que vous êtes confiné chez
vous pouvez pas sortir
on peut pas ça on peut sortir on peut
sentir
y'a pas les gouvernements fin le
gouvernement chinois
ils nous ont pas contactés en disant on
peut pas sortir ou quoi que ce soit on
peut sortir mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
avoir plus de précaution c'est tout
d'accord il ya un gros vent de panique
là où bat n'ont en fait pas du tout non
on peut sortir sur nos courses au
supermarché voir les copains après aussi
un peu de compagnie le vent de panique
c'est sandro moment où quand on sort
bien personnel
c'est ça son voile alors c'est vrai ici
on sent un énorme vent de panique en
chine quand on les écoute ils disent
qu'ils sortent un peu voilà aimé les
écoles sont fermées quand même en fait
en même temps c'est le
chinois donc le virus ou pas le virus
aujourd'hui c'est fermé c'est nous
mélanger les jours d'avant il paraît que
les supermarchés qui sont ouverts
normalement il ya les restaurants les
bars et cafés vais tout saxons mais là
c'est vrai que tout est terminé
alors vous dites que vous mettez un
masque qu'au supermarché parce que là il
ya beaucoup de monde vous balader
normale dans la vue par exemple moi j'ai
un chien je tombais de mon chien je me
balade normal alors il ya certains
français qui vont être rapatriés ce que
vous allez faire la demande ou pas du
tout non non on a reçu un mail pour
savoir si on allait être rapatriés mais
on est aussi vite français mais on a
décidé de vous préférez vous avez pas
peur ont préféré rester là bas non c'est
là d'accord d'accord vous pouvez quitter
la ville korem ou pas non non ce sont
aussi
donc là on pouvait pas quitter hull vous
êtes voilà donc vous ne pouvez pas
prendre l'avion ne pouvait pas quitter
la ville impossible pour l'instant c'est
impossible de rentrer aux socios
d'accord impossible de rentrer l'autre
sortie ils vont embarquer dans les
volcans vise le gouvernement
non il reste deux non les mecs et ben on
pense à vous les chéris vraiment vous
êtes des avants nous avoir répondu il
est 4 heures du matin chez vous vous
faites des normes bisous et on espère
que tout va bien se passer pour vous on
vous embrasse et sans merci est sa 111e
scolari personnes
les séries mildred ça c'est
l'exclusivité mine de rien il faudra
sortir de la ville personne ne peut
rentrer
jimmy ça fait quand même clip est pas
forcément une mesure adaptée si on
confine les jambes hâlées confinés
pendant combien de temps l'épidémie peut
durer jusqu'à avril ou mai donc on va
les laisser chez eux pendant trois ou
quatre mois on va arrêter l'économie
d'un pays pour des gens qui ne sont pas
forcément malade mais par contre la
donne est peut-être en train de changer
en allemagne il ya eu un nouveau cas
sauf que la personne malade ne revient
pas de chine et elle n'a pas été en
contact avec quelqu'un qui revient de
chine et qui serait malade
donc là on va peut-être avoir de
nouveaux cas avec des gens qui
finalement vivent ici et donc ton les
symptômes vont ensemble a su de la
grippe et donc là le vent de panique
peut s'installer à huy abbas à ce poste
et qui permet aux transitions une
question de mousser le môme mutants quoi
qui fait peur on dit que le virus peut
être peut muter et moi les mutants ses
films d'horreur bon moi je vis à vis
russie il va y verrez si la mutation
c'est le fait que le virus s'adapte
il fait en sorte soit d'aller d'être
plus fort soit de mourir pour l'instant
il s'est adapté puisqu'il est passé
la chauve souris à un animal
intermédiaire là l'homme
et puis il a encore muter pour se
transmettre d'homme à homme et donc
soyez va muter être un garçon en or soit
eva but et il va s'éteindre comme ça a
été le cas pour le strass il n'a pas
envie je croyais être contagieux mais
alors est-ce que c'est qu'il est très
contagieux on estime qu'une personne
malade pourrait contaminer 4 à 5
personnes non à titre d'exemple la
rougeole contamine 15 personnes vous
avez la rougeole vous étiez contaminer
15 personnes a besoin de jouer alors là
où j'ai joué nom en com au congo alors
c'est vrai que le congo c'est un peu
loin de chez nous ils ont une épidémie
de rougeole 6000 morts le la rougeole a
plus tu es que ebola dans le même pays
vrai pour autant la vaccin donc parfois
aussi il faut qu'on garde un peu la tête
froide je sais que c'est compliqué mais
voilà pour l'heure alors la situation
est plutôt pour répondre à la question
est-ce qu'il faut avoir peur moi quand
j'entends ça oui assure pas du tout moi
vous vous dites quoi
j'ai mille faut-il encore pour l'instant
non à ce stade là ça reste un virus
respiratoires il y aura forcément
d'autres car il faut s'attendre et des
gens vont probablement mourir en ce
moment
il faut que tu sais il faut savoir que
gerri qui s'est enfoncé dans la gambie
la grippe tue chaque année est la
quatrième personne kalakh dans ce virus
est dans un état apparemment critiqué en
réanimation c'est une personne âgée donc
il ne faudra pas céder à la panique
parce que des gens mais décède
on ne va pas tous mourir de ce virus en
europe est trop tard non pas quand il
est trop tard mais quand on commencera à
voir plus de cas où il faudra détecter
tout le monde et qu'on les gens vont
courir aux urgences alors que les
urgences
ils ont pas de lison patte personnelle
oui mais là quand on va engager
l'hôpital
le problème sera la raison alors est ce
on va voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs faut dit oui à 51%
c'est michmich mais là ils m'ont fait
peur les doutes au désamour